hello and welcome to this video playing
grab ass Safari notta no name but pretty
high rating come on let's get rid of
that okay Queens gambit I guess the
accepted okay hmm it's a very early be
five yeah this is nowadays in fashion
but we'll see what happens night be
seven probably incoming I mean isn't a
four or something I think they nowadays
don't really believe that this is that
this is so great for white
yeah I want to note b3 that's probably
c5 and that's not my not much happening
you can go to see for playing civ 5 for
some reason night 85 Bishop d5 leads
nowhere okay I'm trying this try for
Bishop e3 play on the light squares
probably now it should be ok them you
will go see five I guess when after
busia been through just take it can also
capture any fine of course maybe I'll
take with the porn
I had doesn't look very convincing I
guess this is still better my ideas to
play Bishop of 30 it's not reacting to
that at all that's surprising maybe it's
no problem I mean like takes takes you
five and nine to six isn't that big of a
deal that's very possible
hmm okay
surprising okay I'm just keeping a c5
try to keep it under control would be a
bit much but trying to keep an eye on
that how to do this now we should hear
maybe we should I six bishop asics can
be 35 is the thing okay maybe and this
one form of d1 and possibly just 95 well
looks okay should be a little bit better
here
yeah looks a little bit like a Catalan
that went slightly wrong for black yarn
at c5 or not I think it's I should kick
this opportunity right if you take a
five but that probably will be not very
good yeah i'm looking at one tempo here
i would love I would absolutely need to
have Roxy one here huh okay it's still a
queen 85 what is the deal I can go to c5
right or is he playing pawn to c5 and
this is the thing
I can go inform c5e for should work
night moves I go if five that was the
idea what take on c5 that's also
possible as before now it's not
protected Saudi takes rook TX the screen
before now it looks very nice it should
be a very good position for wide and 5
Queen back probably so I think taking is
just better I guess look check screen
before it's a very very good position
and the Queen takes I should be very
nice very very well in very good shape
after the Queen trade as to have where's
the ala to hit what is he thinking about
group take screen before is just a
flattened that pawn to Bishop d2 was my
intention
check I'm threatening a 5v5 I can 35 ya
know Bishop before is one thing yep this
would be should be good okay if I go
where to go here probably
okay what is the easiest I thought a 5
a-5 was my original idea cannot meet
that night anywhere and I was our
selfish Ops III to firmly protect
everything taking that was rugae one so
okay i'm here i can trick but it doesn't
do that much
I wonder if there's a good way to I can
always return this you know 9 a-5 Luke a
one-take stakes and then bring the King
up yeah that should be should be a
relatively clean good time morning and
night b5 actually hi ok didn't think
about this so much and I should have
take here King h5 it's not that clear I
think I'm taking here check just want to
keep know I shouldn't give him this okay
black forfeits on time yeah not sure
that was the best technical play ever
but probably it was sufficient okie
dokie so let's have a look look at this
I was a bit surprised that he never
reacted to that idea on on the sea fowl
I think it was pretty easy I had I
thought it was pretty easy for him to to
counter that idea just by going c5 but
he never did that even here just I mean
195 I thought I thought just taking and
c5 is fine and I was actually a little
bit worried that but I'm a bit behind in
development with a bishop on c1
something like this he will always get
back yeah surprisingly he went for this
and now I'm have chances to to block
this the sea pawn yeah the engine gives
this month this is interesting so that
he can take go for this setup
interesting and it looks kind of
interesting this can be an idea
yeah after this I'm probably better yeah
the computer wants to go back to a eight
but ok this is slightly better for white
of course at least slightly better if
not more it's a very nice position I'm
blocking the sea pawn and can torch him
forever them and this is just just for
lay know if more strong and and ticks
ticks I can computer wants to play Queen
B five but only I think that the Cancer
is good ultimately i think it was and
quite quite convincing yet taking now
was better right this was a bit better
taking on b7 so that he's not even
coming coming to to c3 and however
should be a winner i hope i didn't
completely completely bungle it getting
a second pawn to keep the beep or net i
think it should be ok each pawn gets
going yeah i'm just in time to keep that
poem yeah he never tried to prevent that
backward see porn issue which was
possible to prevent and at the end he
couldn't yeah I couldn't take it out of
it kind of surprising ok well thanks for
watching